I was working with high-performing
executives in Silicon Valley and noticed
predictable pattern which is that in the
early days these companies they were
really focused that led to success that
success breeded options and
opportunities which if you're not
careful can undermine the things that
led to success in the first place you
fall into the undisciplined pursuit of
more so you're just doing too many
things and they may all be good things
but just too many different things and
so you start to plateau in your progress
or fail altogether as I've studied this
I find that almost universally people
will feel stretched you thin at work or
at home busy but not productive feel
like their days being hijacked by other
people's agenda for them now this is
this is like the problem that
essentialism is seeking to address or
solve
Gregg McEwan how are you my friend I'm
wonderful nice to be with you nice to be
with you as well could we have dressed
any more polar-opposite you've got this
beautiful suit on lovely pressed suit
with a white shirt and I am in a vest
because it's the first hot day of May in
Newcastle listen that's what it is
that's the difference is that I'm in
California so I've got no no reason to
celebrate
but I should celebrate but this you know
beautiful weather and that's that
explains it there's a rarity you know
and you know won't know anybody at all
these people in the Internet I'm allowed
to wear a vest if I want to wear a vest
to podcast with Greg McEwan you know yes
there was an essentialist outfit for
today
this would be this would be it so
essentialism is the word of the day
that's what we're gonna be talking about
today and I I fear that I might be the
arch nemesis of an essentialist or at
least I was for it for quite a long time
so yeah okay why do you say that so I
have a very high desire for novelty I
love new things one of my five core
values is adventure which also pulls me
toward that and another one is curiosity
which opposed me show you what that I
tend to work more than I need to
I enjoy work I enjoy being busy enjoy
doing things and overtime that has led
to me adding an awful lot on my plate
and presuming that I will just be able
to upregulate my productivity or down
regulate my sleep to slot in these extra
things and to the audience at home you
will know this feeling right you will
see from the front row seat you will
watch the slippage of your own terrible
unproductive put on productiveness right
you'll see the the inefficiencies in
your system firsthand you think well I
can add that that project in and all
that will happen is I'll just have to
get rid of those inefficiencies and you
just presume that like a I don't know
like it like a system that the oil will
be greased sufficiently more to allow it
to go in
and I learned I learned the hard way
over a career of 13 years of running
club nights and being a DJ and being a
model and being a podcaster and doing a
coaching and being a fitness and all
this sort stuff I realized that you
can't you can't you can't do at all know
who knew why mean you knew which is
which is the question so why don't you
give us a bit of a background
essentialism and sort of what you do in
your your approach to this look I was
working with high-performing executives
in Silicon Valley and noticed
predictable pattern which is that in the
early days these companies they were
really focused that led to success that
success breeded options and
opportunities which if you're not
careful can undermine the things that
led to success in the first place you
fall into the undisciplined pursuit of
more so you're just doing too many
things and they may all be good things
but just too many different things get
pulled a million different directions
and so you start to plateau in your
progress or fail altogether and as it
turns out this is a pattern that a lot
of people you just said just describes
it a little bit feel the same thing so
as I've studied this I find that almost
universally people will feel stretched
you thin at work or at home busy but not
productive I feel like their days being
hijacked by other people's agenda for
them so this is this is like the problem
that essentialism is seeking to to
address or solve yeah can you pronounce
that German word for me please
which German word and less but better
yet simply they just do the English less
but better it's quite an ugly word hold
on we're gonna find it here now we're
gonna we're gonna do this okay all right
do you know page it's on I know sorry
I'm kindling as well so on oh yeah I
love that you put that on me
look I can't what I know for a fact that
I can't pronounce that German word and I
thought you know it is see if great to
see if Greg can pronounce it you know
yeah me and I can't even find his way is
what we're trying to find it it's it
comes from dieter rams is the one that
least is credited with having made this
idea and and and is ease that I can't
find it now it's fine it doesn't matter
we couldn't we're not gonna be able
pronounce it in any case even if we do
we'll just go all the words and it's a
he's he's this amazing designer who was
the first person to see one of the first
people to see how rubbish it was the way
that we were designing a whole bunch of
furniture so he's working over at Braun
and he has this insight he says everyone
is given example of this at the time if
you want to buy a record player
the first record place did not look like
the record players that you know that if
you think of that right now you know
what that looks like they didn't look
like that they look like massive pieces
of furniture you know because it takes a
while for people to lose the old in any
design and so and so as soon as you're
creating record buys they say well it
has to look like a piece of furniture it
has to look like a closet so thing and
so he was the one that said no hold on
we get rid of the closet we'll just have
the record player and at first when he
designed that people were actually they
were a little hesitant about it they
thought well this is this is they
described that's like a glass coffin my
snow white's coffin or something it was
so pristine and simple and clear but
what's interesting is that forever
afterwards every design of every record
player looked like his
because he'd stripped away all the
non-essential stuff and he'd said this
is this is how it needs to be and he did
that for many many products over 35
years he summarized everything you've
learned into those three words less but
better
I love less but better is it is
phenomenal so people that are listening
and we've mentioned essentialism we've
said less but better in this chaotic how
can people self diagnose if they're a
non-essential astiz I already put I
think are the simplest questions right
like have you ever found yourself busy
but not productive yes or no have you
ever found yourself stretched too thin
at work or at home or both you know have
you ever felt like your days being
hijacked by other people's agenda for
you are you trying to do too many things
and ending up doing them originally well
have you ever found yourself making just
a milimeter progress in many many
different directions someone who says
yes to any of the above especially if
you say yes to all of the above pretty
good chance you know you're operating
more as an on essentialist than an
essentialist currently I mean the good
news about all of this is that it's
people are completely redeemable that
this is the reason that people are
non-essential Asst there's a few but the
primary reason is because they didn't
know they were choosing that they didn't
know there was an alternative they
didn't wake up in the Montt to be an on
essentialist
I just want to do too many things in too
many different directions they just they
just woke they just lived in the world
that happens to emphasize that happens
to persue too many different things and
they just went along with everybody else
and and so that the awakening is where
you say oh hold on there are a group of
people who die operating like that and
that the the results they get our
extraordinary they're able to produce
far far better results at a lower stress
level so they can break through to a
higher point of contribution and enjoy
the process at the same time these
the essentialists and so-and-so learning
that is is a big moment it's a big
change in mindset and therefore you can
change your life quite quickly
afterwards yeah I think there's there's
two main realizations I had when I was
reflecting on that particular area of
your work and one of them was to me
busyness was inbuilt into life and
you're right I didn't know that there
was an alternative as like well this is
just what life is you know yes life is
just life just happens to go a million
miles an hour in across the galaxy and
Isaac setting yeah yeah that's what
that's what you your entry level and the
other the other thing was it gave me
especially the younger businessman it
gave me a sense of accomplishment you
know it made me feel important it made
me feel like I was doing things because
and it was impressive low-key it was
impressive for me to people to say what
do you do and for me to have a laundry
list and be like so what you do well
it's an interesting question actually I
hope you've got about ten minutes so I
do the modeling I do the podcast I've
been on reality TV and I do this thing
and I do that thing and I do you know
you've got this big list so those are
the two things I was like I didn't know
there was an alternative and it made me
feel important and busy and and valued
and I'd wager a lot of other people feel
like that as well yeah and that right
there is interesting this idea of of it
being important that busyness somehow
has come to equal importance is not an
it's not a necessary human condition or
understanding but it does seem to be
this current cultures understanding and
so I remember talking to one more time
and I was asking yeah so how are you
and she said I'm so busy so busy
great I'll tell you I've slept on every
four hours a night for the last two
weeks that's how busy I am you know and
she's smiling I mean first of all why is
she smiling
[Music]
[Laughter]
and-and-and what she didn't say this but
what I think she was saying was look I
hate to break it to you Greg I'm just a
little more important than you are you
know get to sleep a normal night's rest
but I am under so much demand you see me
after all they're merely exactly that's
how important I am and she didn't know
of course that she was right you know
speaking to well to an aspiring
essentialist you know and say she didn't
know that this was not this is not
impressive to me this is not an
achievement to me and so it was it will
lead to a very genuinely friendly
conversation and a couple of weeks after
that she came back to me said okay my
goodness I about completely stripped
away the way I was doing it sleeping
properly I've like made prioritized
decisions about what I actually want to
go after and don't and I feel this
increase of productivity right my stress
is going down my productivity is going
up like this is the value proposition of
essentialism and and it's in that story
it's also the nonsense of nahma
sensualism what a con that it is yeah I
think it's a Ray Dalio quote that felt
like it should have been in essentialism
yeah and it says a truth in this life is
that you can have anything you want but
you can't have everything you want
yeah and accepting that genuinely truly
not just going yeah yeah sounds good
sounds nice mate but I'm gonna get I'll
get I'll get the other thing after I've
had this thing so I'll have this
anything then I'll have the next
anything and you know that that's the
everything mentality and I wonder how
much of this comes from people not
knowing what they want in life yeah
absolutely
it comes from people it comes from
people not taking the time to explore
that you know they're just they're just
going along and the busyness baguettes
busyness and that's what everyone else
is doing so they're just they're
actually in a way
they're not having to make any decisions
they're just doing what everybody else
is doing oh they're doing that what my
ex when Abe is doing it I mean it used
to be just you know keeping up with the
Joneses but now of course it's social
media keeping up the Joneses which is a
much different challenge right you're
getting to compare yourself to
everybody's best possible version of
themselves basically sort of a form of
lying you know because it's so curated
and different than the rest of their
life and you're comparing yourself
against the best of everybody's so this
is really like a recipe for for non
essentialism you know it's not just
opinion overload
I mean if rather it's not information
over it is opinion overload we're just
getting crammed with all this stuff and
so our job is to try and push all of
that away and get quiet and ask what not
just even what do I want although that's
not bad
so what am I supposed to do what what is
what is my mission what is the thing I
came here to do what what what don't
come here to do that that is it that is
a completely different kind of question
and as you start to explore that you
find that you already have more answers
than you realize but it comes from
inside of you instead of just from all
this outside stuff and you can start to
have quite instead of the fear of a
missing out or FOMO you start to have
the joy of missing out right or Joe
Meaux died oh yeah yes Joe Meaux is
ought to be a singer but we already make
a song to it you could do that but Joe
Meaux is a yeah you discover that just
because other people do in fact you like
not doing things that other people are
doing you start to go yeah that's great
for you you can celebrate it for them
but that's not what I'm doing
that's what I'm about so what I'm
supposed to be doing in my life and you
start to feel this joy and momentum in
doing as I keep saying what you came
here to do
before we get until I want to ask the
question which is how do we do that what
are the steps that we can take toward
identifying that and getting rid of the
trivial many but that deprogramming
right of the existing societal norms the
paths of least resistance your genetic
predisposition your traumas in the
coping mechanisms you've got with that
is something I'm swimming in at the
moment I've got an amazing blog post
that I'm going to send to you after
we've finished and I know that I've just
completely teased that to everyone
that's listening however the author of
the blog post is going to come on the
podcast in the next couple of weeks oh
I've got a big announcement about that
it's phenomenal you're some fella but
wrote the best thing I've read on the
Internet
this year and one of the things that he
was talking about there was about sort
of deprogramming the societal norms and
getting rid of all that stuff and that
foam overseas jomo paradigm that you've
just come up with there to me is present
in a lot of different areas of life so
for instance as soon as you see
discomfort in training physical training
as something to actually lean into as
something that is a signal that you're
doing something right as opposed to a
signal that you're doing something wrong
but it takes time to program yourself
you go into the gym for the first time
when you do a difficult workout and you
feel you're gonna die you're in the
floor and you want to throw up and
you're sweating and you knees her and
all this stuff happens and there's some
very real physical adaptations that need
to happen before you can go like fully
in but once those have occurred and
presuming you're doing it safely the
discomfort is the signal of progress
right and it's kind of the only way you
can do that is by learning a hang on
this is me moving forward this is me
doing the right thing and the the Jomo
as it seems the joy of missing out again
is that it's like I'm missing out that's
fantastic that means that I'm focusing
on what I should be focusing on I'm not
getting swept away with the trivial many
yeah I think that's absolutely right to
think about those signals that will be
new signals so that when other people
are digging your zagging you know when
other people saying yes you're saying
other people saying no you're saying yes
because you're trying to you're not
trying to be like everybody else anymore
yeah youyou can't be distinctive and
everything though you you are very very
right
okay so how do we do it where do we
start you've got me Greg I'm here I'm a
nightmare I'm doing too much how do I
start to bring order to chaos okay so
you're asking that question in like
still a hypothetical way or you could be
so we could do it in a literal way right
so we just do it with you right now
I mean um okay so tell me first thought
what is something that's essential to
you it's very important to you but
you're under investing in it currently
you might be doing something but you're
under investing go first thoughts
writing
okay what-what-what does success look
like for you in writing one new article
per week and that you're putting out in
your blog to your to your newsletter
that's what you want to do how are you
doing it right now how much you managing
to do currently zero okay good so good
okay so this is so that when you say
you're not you're not publishing any you
are not doing any writing [ __ ] so
I've been I've been just stick you
lating over the the font size of the
website and and the the tiny little
things that I know is really a glorified
version of procrastination to put me off
from actually putting in hard work I
have six half-finished articles all of
which require two hours of focused work
to be really good and I really like them
yes but there's just six half-finished
meals and they're all in the edge and
they're all in the kitchen yeah I like I
like how practical that example is I
think a lot of people can relate to that
okay so how long have you been doing
those six and a half articles how long
have they been sort of sitting there
getting cold probably since the
beginning of lockdown that's maybe a
maybe yet yeah okay so a couple of
months yeah yeah you you started working
on them then started working on one and
then did a bit and then I would go oh
that's a bit that's enough for today and
then it when I came back I'd go I'd go
do some else I got podcast do I got
business caller I got training or I got
you know life yep come back start a new
I was that one's already it's kind of
doing I'll just do a new one does that
illusion sorry a lure of novelty again
gets me an own you know the new new idea
yeah you're more excited to start the
thing than to finish the thing that's
yes that's it
okay so so
tell me tell me one of those articles
what's just one of them that you what's
the first one you worked on in fact ten
things I learned from speaking to the
smartest people on the planet for 200
hours yeah okay well that's good that's
a good title if you ladies and gentlemen
Greg McEwan say that the title of my
articles is good with that okay so what
is the minimum number of what what is
the minimum amount of work that needs to
be done to the article in its current
format before you can put it out no I
don't even know which is embarrassing
but you haven't done it all - yeah all
ten all ten things are done each of the
common themes they're kind of fleshed
out a proof a proof read it's the unsexy
stuff go back through proofread it make
sure that I haven't used too much
hyperbole check if there's one concept
I'm not Ritu sure if that should be in
and I think part of me scared as well
that when I reopen that Pandora's Box at
the moment its I know it's not done but
it is closed and when I reopen that I
get reminded of the fact that it's still
going does that make sense well it's an
interesting point you're saying you're
saying that in its unfinished closed
position it feels a sort of done yeah
that's very interesting right you're
saying like stopping working on
something has a feeling of closure of
anything it can't that is officially
undone I can check that off that this is
informally procrastinated yep sure
that's it that is hit well done it move
on the next one let's quickly get the
next article into the same progress
slated you are working through these a
storm okay
what is what is really stopping you from
publishing an article so I think it's
publishing the article is a
perfectionist trap a little bit that I'm
like I feel like there's a little bit of
pressure you know I have a bunch of
friends who are all very competent at
writing online and I think Ronnie it
needs to be like [ __ ] war and peace
and then another bit of it's just the
the working process of writing isn't yet
coming as easily to me as podcasting is
I've never procrastinated on podcasting
never once because it feels like a high
calling it's something which comes to me
incredibly naturally there's also a very
interesting way that the format pulls
you through because it's like a
treadmill you know you don't actually
have to overcome your own inertia to do
a podcast I can't now stop talking to
you and just give up halfway I mean I
could but it would be really weird
it'd be really weird if I now stopped
talking so you've got some externalized
accountability you've got some
motivation from the person that you're
speaking to I think that the the nature
of a conversation is is quite different
which is also why book clubs and stuff
as successful I suppose they give you
that external accountability to keep you
moving through something and get over
your own inertia yes so you need to
choose a day that your podcast goes out
no matter what right three days a week
at the moment Greg we are doing three
episodes a week no but I mean I mean
with your plot with your blog yes okay
yes I mean having a set date where you
say okay I it goes out on which use your
day what's today
may 18th all right may 18th and then
every week after that you put out a blog
correct now your body language when I
said that was like so non-committal turn
the camera like absolutely not
committing to doing that I'll say hey
I'm here because it would be awkward not
to in the middle of this podcast but
there's no way I'm doing that that's
what I heard from you maybe am I wrong
maybe no I I look the the the thing in
it for everyone that's listening you're
hearing and watching and feeling me go
through the turmoil of something that I
think we all experience which is I want
to do a thing I genuinely do or else I
wouldn't have started it I wouldn't have
spent my time I wouldn't have started
learning about the process of writing
and spoken to people and stuff but
there's something there's something
that's happening with that that's
getting in the way and there are so many
still now having started to strip back
as much as I can and focus on the get
rid of the trivial many and focus on the
vital few there's still a lot of things
pulling on my time and the urgent gets
in the way of the important a lot which
is a nightmare yeah well you're doing
three three podcasts a week you know you
could say okay four until I publish my
first article I'm only doing two a week
I'm not allowed to do the third until I
get my first out how would that would
help the podcast momentum lean help you
you know keep you accountable towards
this new trade-off look I think that I
think what's at the heart of the matter
for you with this is that you want the
first article to be of the same quality
as the other writers that you admire and
have read their work from that's what I
think this is about and I want to
encourage you to have the courage to be
rubbish
[Laughter]
- just go success is hosting that first
podcast if at first blog and here's how
I would recommend you do it I would
recommend that you send it to your list
as a link to your blog rather than the
whole content is in the email right and
here's why because if you do it that way
you can keep updating it as you need to
[Music]
right so the first version you send out
on the day you send that link doesn't
have to be the permanent state of that
article it's just how it is now and own
it right there in the in the email you
send out to everybody you just say
assume that's how you're sending it to
people how you're gonna get send it out
to every combination of that and sending
it through social media and stuff like
that Lee say the same thing you just
have the link to be somewhere where you
can keep editing it over time I'll tell
you something happened to me that's
similar to this I once wrote at like
late at night a very rubbish eats on
LinkedIn and it asked me to be an
influencer on LinkedIn and it was it was
rubbish and I just was new to that
platform at the time it was brand new
platform that they were using and they
said and so I post this thing the number
one career mistake capable people make
just type my favorite was post it and
the next morning when I wake up sixty
thousand people have viewed it and
there's a ton of comments and a ton of
criticism it wasn't all negative but I
just written this like you know just
sort of two three paragraphs and I like
jumped in and started editing
immediately and improved it and improve
it a couple of million people read that
tooth maybe more than at the end it was
like it was relatively viral piece at
the time and it was so encouraging that
okay so it started off as this piece but
we were able to improve it as we went
now that's not necessarily how you
always want it to be but you have to get
over the hump here so you have to lower
the hump that you're trying to get over
this mental hum of it has to be
fantastic where I can't put it out put
something out is it's it's a smaller
amount it isn't going to be perfect I
don't even know what that would mean a
perfect article but you will get
feedback and you will learn and you'll
be in the same mode before we started
this idea what did you say I can't find
their name the skill take off and that
sensation and the skill take off and so
maybe what you say is I'm gonna I'm just
gonna publish maybe you say I'm gonna
publish oh yeah I don't know okay and so
I am trying to encourage you to it is is
really my probably my biggest insight
since writing essentialism is that
is that is that people people there what
there's a piece of feedback people often
get it's not the most common feedback
but it is regular enough that I
definitely noted it and it is where
they'll say oh yeah it's hard isn't it
essentialism though it's hard that
focusing or what's essential and and not
on what's non-essential it has you know
and in fact somebody once said to me
they say look you know essential issues
should come with a warning this will be
the hardest thing that you will ever do
and for a year or two I absorb that type
that that like line and would share that
with people well the thing a problem
with this engine is hard thing you'll
ever do and what a con that is that's a
totally non essentialist idea it's like
completely wrong it's only it's only the
harder thing to do because you're a
non-essential astraying to be an
essential like you you're trying to be
in the centrist in a non essentialist
way you're like I have to do this
perfectly right now this is not what
essentialism is about I think there's a
way to do essentialism that so easy and
that's what we need to do we must cut
away all these layers of get in the way
of you actually publishing what you've
written
no need the fancy website you don't need
the article to be perfect whatever that
means you don't even have to have ten of
them doesn't have to be perfect it just
needs to be published and then the
feedback will come and then you'll learn
something and then you can progress to
the next step you've got you've got to
have this and this is only a couple of
the things one can do to make them
easier but but that is my primary
learning since essential as it was
written that's a very cool way to look
at it and I've seen and heard other
people as well say the challenge of the
discipline pursuit of less you know
especially I think relinquishing
relinquishing your hand on novelty is
something that I want to get into in a
second because I you know for the people
out there who similarly to me like
adventure like new things new
experiences it just leads to yeses
all over the place just because you
think well that's interesting
oh well that's interesting well that
could be fun well that could be fun well
I I could I could do that and then you
you poles talk rationalize it right you
do what this is that this is the most
[ __ ] insidious way the e post hoc
rationalize it all the non-essential
ists listening which is everybody most
the most insidious way that you
rationalize doing too much is by hedging
your risk that's the most insidious way
because it's got a kernel of truth in it
it's got a kernel of truth in it that if
you were to do two things instead of one
you have your risk if that one thing
goes [ __ ] yeah but you then take it to
way if I do 100 things and one of them
goes to [ __ ] that's only 1% yeah and you
don't realize that the price that you
pay for doing a hundred things is that
you've only gone one unit of distance
over a hundred things as opposed to a
hundred units of distance over one thing
yeah that's right and it also the other
faulty the other false assumption in
that is the idea that all opportunities
or actions are randomly like successes
randomly assigned to those 100 like if
you Annette if you couldn't understand
any cause and effect between anything
you might be best to just do a hundred
things and you only make an inch
progress in all of them but at least
you'll make an inch progress in one
thing that's going to work because it's
totally random that's fine it's so you
want to believe life is completely
random fine you go with you live that
one out and see how that works for you
right but on the basis that and this is
the first principle of essentialism is
to explore what's essential rheya is to
actually create space looking for the
thing you feel really good about
pursuing the thing that you feel you're
best built to do and and so and so in
that process you come to a point of view
that says I'm built to do this and not
to do that so I'm gonna go strong on the
thing that I am
that passionate about I think is
relevant right now I mean all of those
things are risk mitigation techniques so
that you can then lean into something
fully that you're actually you know is
your highest point of contribution and
one of the things for me about that is
writing I mean there's so many career
paths I would have been rubbish at and
failed at in a sort of capital F way
right like just not that you wouldn't
worked well
I I went big on something not because I
was a height like not not because I had
a high tolerance for risk because I am
actually quite risk-averse and I wanted
to do things that I really felt strong
and good at and so on and I think that's
what we have to do you have to yeah
instead of thinking it's all random you
take the time to explore figure out what
you really can make a great contribution
and then go big in it what about someone
that says well I'm not great at anything
yes so you can start with I mean you
know what we're talking about here is
criteria right what criteria to use to
evaluate what to do and you start off
with maybe like well what the things I
have no interest in well don't do that
stuff fishing but you know like fishing
don't do fishing right is because your
mates are doing fish don't mean you have
to go fishing but I have lots of people
who love skiing
I always feel this guilt like I need to
do some skiing for some good scheme you
want to be able to go skiing you know
it's you love it you would love it you
would love it
you always feel this and I'm like no I'm
not interested not interest is to start
with the stuff you're not interested in
start with the stuff that you go yeah I
not only am I not good at that I could
not imagine ever being good at that that
is not my thing so you should start at
the extremes right the periphery and
move forward so you don't have to say
what am i great at but you can say what
am i interested in but do I think I
might have a little bit of talent for
you know you you look on like you know
Britain's Got Talent or whatever the
talent show is and you see these people
in these but just terrible of that thing
and they got high passion really low
talent for it and you feel for those
people right or you wonder why they
don't understand it what we're looking
for is things that have you feel some
passion for that you think you might be
quite good at that you think you could
become good at it
and yeah it meets a need in the world
and
overlap that's where your highest point
of contribution can lie and then over
time you're developing that more and
more narrowly so that over time is your
competency increases you aren't just
interested in doing the things you're
good at you are looking for the thing
you would be the best at really greater
eventually down the journey it's like
could I be the best in the world at this
thing you know maybe maybe this is a
tiny group of people who can do this
thing but that's that's a you know that
you increase your selectivity as your
competence increases I like the idea of
using inversion and a contrasting effect
to work out where you don't go it's the
same for the easiest way to avoid being
depressed is to work out not what makes
you happy but how you would make a happy
person depressed I would fall asleep I'd
[ __ ] up with their nutrition and make
sure they didn't get any daylight and
you know do all of the different bits
and pieces and you're like oh yeah well
that makes a happy person depressed and
go Rocky what's the what's the
implication of that it's also funny that
that's as he was saying about the
different things that sounded to me like
a hell no like would you go would you go
fishing
hell no would you go with ski hell no
and as past modern wisdom guests and
good buddy Derek Siver's says it's
either hell yes or no and that ties into
something I actually wanted you to run
us through which is that the 90 percent
rule do you take us through that yeah so
you imagine a you know everything every
option that you have on on a that could
be plotted on a continuum from 0 to 100
and it's an importance continuum so an
importance continuum a zero is it's
totally unimportant and 100 is
completely important absolutely
essential right so everything you know
whether it's writing this article that
you just talked about or exercise are
doing the next podcast really going on
YouTube like or every activity can be
plotted on this
continuum and what I'm encouraging
people to do is to say anything that is
underneath 90 percent anything that's
lower than 90 percent important you
question and maybe even eliminate you're
looking for just the things that are 90
percent or above essential vitally
important relationships you know
absolutely must do before I die projects
you know habits that I know will make
the rest of my life significantly
improved and different might even make a
difference with my children
grandchildren
you're looking for those things because
every time you do something that's below
90 percent you're taking it away from
something that is 90 percent robust
you're making a trade-off people don't
really know about that they don't see it
that way often so they just think well
is this good well good might be 40 it
might be 40% important 30% boy that's
good it's fine it's fine the wrong with
doing that but they don't aware that
they're taking it away from the thing
that is absolutely vital so I'm always
encouraging people like look at the
extremes look at the things that a 90
percent are important and invest there
look at the stuff that's below 10% and
just eliminate there make the trade-off
between the two so that you can actually
go further faster on the things that
matter I think what some people may be
concerned about is that sounds like a
very totalitarian disciplined life
rather I'm not allowed to have cake
because cake isn't contributing to my
highest sense of importance and I I used
to like YouTube but Greg and Chris told
me the youtubes on e that I really I
looked at the importance of that and
that's only thirty percent so now I've
got to delete the YouTube app and now I
just feel like I'm this kind of robot
that's sort of rolling through life so
how do people find that balance between
turning on and turning it off of having
the focus on the essential few whilst
being able to give us enough kind of
leeway to to live a life that doesn't
feel like it's completely under
and a super control all the time well
what it sounds like you just said is
that freedom creativity exploration is
really important to you
that wasn't me that's I'm alright
without cake I love it I love me a bit
of cake but right now it's summertime
you know just saying other people might
find what we described as being really
stringent all I'm saying is that if if
somebody feels that something important
to them is probably being violated so
they haven't got their list right yet
when you're working on the 90% and above
you're not you're not feeling rigid and
controlled you're feeling free and
liberated from all this nonsense that
you don't value that's keeping you back
from living the things you actually do
want so there's a lot of joy there's
more joy in the 90% than above then
there is probably in the rest of the 90
percent combined when when I'm working
on something that's meaningful to me
that's inspiring to me I mean I'll give
you example just this week so so it was
a it was doing a you know having an
evening with my children my wife and and
we were doing s'mores which yes
I mean even without the wife and the
children the s'mores on their own would
be in the 90 percent for me so and so so
we just spent the evening doing the
outside over a fire together enjoying
that time that was a 90% or above for me
that's not stringent and rigid that's
playfulness and and joyfulness and it's
a way better than me just sort of going
okay I'll just I'll just scan social
media and just be at my own infinite
scanning on that in some room somewhat
like that that's what we're talking
about we're saying get rid of all that
stuff that doesn't feed you isn't joyful
there isn't there isn't taking you
forward and and so I think that things a
bit of creativity and imagination as to
what really matters for people to have a
good vision of this yeah it's
interesting with time isn't it the way
that time works because it's it's the
only thing you can't choose to not spend
now you can't not spend time
you can choose to not spend your money
and it's the mad thing about people that
are able to get in shape other people
are able to accumulate wealth like they
do that by having an asymmetry between
what they bring in and what they put out
yeah there isn't an equivalent with time
yeah there's no time bank you can't say
today I'm gonna just take half of this
time I don't know what to do with it so
I'll put it over there wait while I
figure this out right it's being spent
at exactly the same rate all of the time
no matter what it's more like it's more
like a conveyor belt going past and that
that that's moving no matter what you
use it for so it's it's it's its present
yeah what you're saying is true there's
a quote from Navarre back and I've been
playing around with recently which is
play stupid games win stupid prizes what
does that mean to you so it meant a lot
I've spent a lot of time thinking about
these little that as an aphorism um play
stupid games win stupid prizes to me
means what is the what would be winning
the thing that you're doing right now so
for instance what would be winning
always replying to an Instagram DM
message within 30 minutes all day every
day what what's that what's the prize
play a stupid game win a stupid prize a
stupid prize doesn't exist it's a
satisfying of some people who wouldn't
have cared if you'd waited a week to
reply to them who maybe you're never
gonna see again who you maybe never met
play another stupid game if you want to
take it to a kind of a little bit more
vicious degree pay a stupid game which
would be have unprotected sex with
someone that you don't know after a
night out that is playing a very stupid
game what's the prize that you win for
that when you compare it with the
alternative of having protected sex what
would be play a stupid game of texting
while you drive as opposed to waiting
until you get to your destination that's
a very stupid game to play when you win
a stupid prize what's the prize it are
well the lads in the group chat got the
Meem off me a little bit quicker than if
I'd waited and I got to have a little
bit of a giggle at the lights as opposed
to sit and look out the window or
whatever it is play stupid games win
stupid prizes slots into essentialism
somehow for me yeah I think that's right
because I remember working with her with
maybe like 50 of the top leaders from
from American industry and as I walked
into the room it's a very it was a very
sad dark oak room it's very secretive
Beattie actually very interesting and it
wasn't there was nothing bad being done
there but it was just like very kind of
elite feeling as you walked into the
room and I like to have liked all the
people I talked to it there but the the
the overwhelming sensation I had in that
room was here is a group of people that
one at the wrong game what's that mean
well one of them was vulnerable at one
point and just said look my relationship
with my teenager is completely shot
right now and is almost ready to leave
the house and I just don't have
relationship with like so it's
everything's rough between us and so
here he is he's he's got up the
corporate ladder but he's won at a game
that now he realizes didn't matter or
certainly didn't matter in comparison to
these relationships that he's taken for
granted over those same years and so I
just think there's many of the prizes
that people think are the most important
things so I don't mean the total trivia
I think there's many goals people set
that that actually if they were if they
spent a little longer pondering them and
thinking about them they would find
that's the wrong game I I won at the
wrong thing I got I did I achieved it I
got there but then it was like you know
it was it was unsatisfying when I
actually arrived there that wasn't what
it was actually that is not what the it
was unsatisfying achievement that's what
I mean by and that's where
the Explorer before you exploit
importance comes in at the beginning of
looking at your options of assessing the
things that you want yes and there's
there's a few ways of thinking about
exploration right one is one is just
intellectually here are my options let
me evaluate the options in front of me a
second way of thinking about it is what
I think one's highest priority is which
is to protect our ability to prioritize
protect our ability to discern yeah all
of us have many many non-essential
voices outside of us and inside of us
right just all different a mind is
telling us a million thing all you're
gonna do this and that matters and how
how you compared to that person and look
at competitions and comparisons and
complaining voices and all these voices
right there's all of this noise
and then there's another voice where my
friends it even says it this way he says
he says there's there's a lot there's a
scared voice and then there's a sacred
voice my distinction would be adding
this many many scared voices and one
sacred voice right and we all know that
of the voice I think I think almost all
of us have experienced in where we just
go that's right that's wrong and you
know and nobody else had to tell it to
you you didn't learn it from someone you
just you just know that's the right
thing to do in this moment that's the
wrong thing to do in this moment and if
we are quiet enough that voice becomes
the voice that leads us so exploring
what is essential to me at its highest
manifestation means tuning into
amplifying that voice of conscience that
really guides you in the right direction
if you do that today in small ways you
don't wake up 20 years from now and go
oh my goodness I just I've just given
myself 20 years to the wrong goal that's
what I think it means that's scary you
know the tweeted something I can't even
remember where I found it but it stuck
with me for years
I tweeted this the other day true hell
is when the person you are meets the
person you could have been
yeah that's I you know I like I like
that sentiment is a bit scary like you
say I I want I want I give you a story
so I was staring at myself in the mirror
dressed from head to toe in a
stormtrooper costume good luck good luck
well it was a moment that's certainly
why it was and I was thinking about
buying it this was like a you know
pretty close to movie level quality suit
right and I'm in buy I'm in like late
30s looking at myself in this mirror and
I look it was for Halloween right and it
I still kind of I think I get why I
thought that was a cool thing why it
might be a fun idea but as I'm staring
at the mirror I'm struck by two things
completely at the same time one is
there's not one part of me that wants
this anymore
right like what why am I even thinking
about I do not want that I do not want
this and the second in the same moment I
realized that for thirty years I've had
in my mind the idea that one day I would
buy this because thirty years previously
that's when Return of the Jedi had come
out a my older brother one of my older
brothers had said to me would it be so
cool to own like cost you right from you
know throw in the movies like movie
level quality cost you stuff and my
little like young self influenced by my
brother saying this just it just like
caught on and that little goal stuck
with me for all those years now this is
the power of cause we get that goals are
really powerful that they're one of my
professors once said they're the theory
that works but what he was saying is
that they work too well once you have a
goal you can get on autopilot and now
you're racing down some path to get
something but really you didn't stop to
question so what I'm saying here is be
careful that some of the goals that we
set aren't stormed are they strong
troopers you know should we just have
eliminated them already could we give up
on them halfway because we go no that
doesn't even matter but if someone else
wanted to do that swatch Nagle wanted to
do that I don't have to do that yeah you
know just cuz the rocks do it doesn't
mean I have to do it the rock is cool
I am I absolutely loved that I had took
a max on and he is a man who has gone
through about was big of a 180 as you
can imagine from this what was it called
a frat frats literacy or something he
created a tiny literary genre which was
like party boy party boy stories type
thing and here he'd gone through this
big and then he's done a decade of
psychotherapy and a ton of internal work
and this guy is so so [ __ ] aware now
and just completely present speaking is
true forward just stripping away ego
left right and center really really
delivering he's phenomenal I love the
person he's not would have hated the guy
that he was back there but I love the
person he is now and I'm you see when
someone makes such a change like that
and you've got these weird like epochs
in your life right you've got like the
the kid then the teenager then like the
young kind of 20s then like the mid-20s
then that you know did it and um it
takes a lot of work you know it takes a
lot of work to realize that you thought
that having a faster car than your mates
when you were 19 was a big deal but now
you're 32 when your wife loves you and
you've got two kids and a dog that you
care about and because you never
questioned whether or not still having a
faster bigger better car was it's just
it's like it's just there it's just a
modus operandi right and it's just
running below you and you kinda don't
really realize and the stream just takes
you along I absolutely love I love that
concept you touch it on something
actually that I had I had in my notes I
wanted to bring up which is why is it's
so hard to cut losses is it just sunk
cost fallacy is it just oh well I've got
this far with the huge tech company
which is destroying my relationship with
my teenager I might as well I might as
well go all the way is that why people
have a fear is there any
thing else yeah because you're having to
face the potentially poor decision of
not having cut off yesterday of the day
before they before that and so you're
more the longer it goes the harder it is
to admit that we weren't wise in the
previous scenario and so so yes of
course we want to well you've heard the
old metaphor right of the the how do you
catch a monkey but you've heard this
right how do you catch a monkey there's
a trap and you the monkey puts their
hand in the trap you never heard this
you put the monkey puts their hand in
the trap and and they can't once they
once their hand is in the trap they're
holding onto the you know the nuts in
there are the fruit whatever's in there
and because their hand this clenched
they can't get their hand out right
because it's smaller if they can put the
hand in but not be enough that they can
get the hand out so they want to hold on
to it and I I thought for a long time
that this was this was just sort of a
you know made-up massive or whatever but
you can go on YouTube and there's
somebody who's actually done this and
it's actually it's really brilliant
little video and and they just first of
all they just will not let go and he's
completely trapped and the man's coming
over to get him and this it will not let
go of this is this thing and then right
as the man actually takes hold of the
monkey he does let go already gets
focused on something else
and that's the key to letting go is we
have to focus on the next something
that's more important to us something
that actually is that is a deep better
version of what we want to be so that we
can let go of these old these old things
they don't matter anymore let them go I
mean this idea of not growing up holding
on to the 20 year old version of as then
holding on to the 25 year old version of
us or not but it's a failure to mature
it's a failure to thrive we're trying to
win yesterday's battle try in
yesterday's version of the of the world
and so and so I think that I think that
it's we got onto the onto the monkey and
catching monkeys anyway so that's a
monster your question but no you are I
feel like that we we holding on to all
this investment we've made in something
and we've just got to look to the next
thing it's actually better and it gives
us the courage
let go of the thing that we will keep
holding on to yeah there's a story from
Kemal Robert Kahn who's Nevarez brother
and I heard him on the podcast just
before Christmas and he lost pretty much
all of his blood in an operation
accidentally though it's the sutures
burst on his artery and he basically
bled out and he was anemic and all this
stuff happened in terrible pain and love
yourself like your life depends on it I
was just about to come out the second
version and he'd sold tons
self-published and he was like the the
perfect patient zero for who needs drugs
and the doctors are like if anyone ever
needed opium he opiates it to you like
you are the guy for drugs so he's making
them and he gets the first proof
uncorrect admonish script whatever it is
back and he realizes that because of the
drugs that he's on that he can't view
the punctuation with enough dexterity
and that resolution that he needs to cuz
he wants every word it's quite short
book it's only that maybe 70 pages or
something and he wants everything you it
needs to craft every single word every
line break every piece of punctuation
all the rest of it he realizes he can't
do it so he just stops taking the drugs
and he's in pain but he asks something
which is greater than his pain he has
the book and the book allows him to
transcend what it is that he's suffering
with right and I loved that story and I
wouldn't have I would have never heard
and I've never heard him tell it on his
different any other podcast it's just
cuz I was being like a bit nosy about
the pain that you've gone through in
this recent near-death
[Music]
it's so powerful it's like allegorical
almost you like look you've got this
this thing which occurs which is greater
than your suffering and it allows you to
transcend the difficulty of just
existing of just getting through your
day-to-day life and that's kind of like
the monkey thing right it's like you
know if if only you could let go of the
thing that you were do you thought you
wanted to move on to the thing which you
truly want and one of the best ways for
that to happen is to have something
which you know that you truly want so
much more because it makes letting go an
awful lot easier yeah I was you know
I've just had just about too long
a podcast and one of the reasons I did
it was because I was talking to one of
my podcasting friends and and he has
this great line he says he says success
traps are harder to get out of them
failure traps and that to me is so such
a brilliant illustration of the problem
you're describing and the cure of it is
higher purpose
it's always something it's it's serving
someone else's doing something more
meaningful so you get out of the trap of
being so self-centered in life where
we're worried constantly about how will
appear and what will do and how we
you're gonna get rid of I think that's
probably the ultimate monkey trap is
just that we haven't got past ourselves
yet and and and and this is where all
the suffering is this is where all the
non-essential habits lie as soon as we
step out to serve somebody else I think
a lot of that non-essential stuff starts
to fall apart fall away and we we can
get out of the trap Scott Barry Kaufman
his new book transcend is is precisely
about that he talked yeah it readers
Maslow's hierarchy of needs and he talks
about you can't you know he literally
believes that you can't reach your
fullest potential without serving others
yeah it's suspended Maslow you know yes
yeah he was talking he said yeah go on
this story about Maslow's you hear about
his mother-in-law I think it's his
mother-in-law and he said that he said
his mother-in-law was the most
actualized person that he'd ever met and
she would she was like just a mom just a
mom Olivia at home you know wasn't the
picture of the the guy on the top of the
mountain you know just slaying
businesses and driving fast cars and
doing all that stuff but he said she was
the most actualized person he'd ever met
well in towards the end of his life he
rebuilt his own model but he it was just
too late because it was already like
become popularized and everybody no
one's updated it so the top of his model
was not self actualization by the end of
his life it was self transcendence
and and that that distinction makes all
the difference doesn't it I have met so
many people trying to pursue a self
actualized life and you can feel
or the absence of some what matters so
much more than self-actualization as
important the self-actualization is and
sort of going after goals are just
achieving them but self transcendence
where you really are in contribution
mode where you really are in service
mode to a calling to a purpose that's
higher and more important than that our
own sort of proximate concerns this is
such this is the big distinction to me
this is the difference that I'm always
looking for in people this is the
difference I want to see in myself to
transition to be to live a life of
contribution not just one of
productivity or just of you know sort of
external worldly success that that's
that's really what I want I think I
think Maslow did appreciate that
distinction for the end but then got
miss quoted in a sense what are the red
are you do you feel like you're moving
in the right direction are you still
getting yourself towards the top of this
newly extended hierarchy of needs I mean
for me for me when I think about you
know it's an ongoing journey but when I
think about the last almost 20 years now
that journey that essentialist journey
not just the book and all that but I
mean the the journey my own life has
been all about that transition so for me
it looks like it looks like investing
primarily in my relationship with Anna
my wife and our four children and really
seriously investing in it not saying lip
service oh yes they're the most
important people in my life but actually
building those relationships so when I
travel for example about 80 percent of
the time I'll take one of my children
with me so that we have that one-on-one
time it means that it means that instead
of joining that book club or going to
that the larger the golfing thing of the
tennis tour of you just say no to all of
that and you just try to make your own
children like not just your best friends
but also your best friends people that
you really want to be with and spend
time together with
and the effect of all of that has been
that the culture that has been created
is something really special so even as
my children now are like either three of
them are teenagers I could not believe
ten years ago that my relationship now
would be what it is with teenagers now I
was a teenager I know lots of teenagers
understand that journey I worked over
the years and I've got a lot of respect
for obviously young people I'm not
knocking them but it isn't that this is
just completely not like any of the
stereotypical descriptions you know
worst problems I like my one of my my
teenage son is like he reads too many
books he reads like late into the night
he reads fiction and he loves it and he
that's like a that's my biggest problem
with him I'm Alicia I'm not kidding they
said they got delightful and they played
together they spend time together they
did they just spent five hours this is
like a week ago five hours upon a hill
close to where we live we live up in the
hills and they were filming for my
eldest daughter wants to be a director
and she's due taking a film class at
university right now and she's just I
mean she's 17 but she's like you know
really like focused about what she wants
to do and her highest point contribution
and so she went up there and led a they
took him it's a good how is it called a
princess bride you know the movie
princess yeah okay so she had to redo a
scene from any movie and they chose a
scene from that movie the IO came power
and a scene for those that know this
classic and and they redid it absolutely
scene by scene took them five hours to
do it
we didn't hear of one problem the whole
time we weren't there we didn't oversee
any of it the video is brilliant it's
like frame by frame the same as the
original they were all the actors they
had did the whole costumes they've
fulfilled it whatever I think it was fit
out 50 points she got 50 points for this
you just got the result of a couple of
days ago that to me he's like
illustrative that's like a version of
what essentialism looks like
it was the natural outgrowth of
investing in something 90% are important
for years and years and it just now
bears this fruit all the time this is
flowing of it and and so you know I just
share that story because because I think
that this is this is what what you just
said about Maslow and his mother is now
is no throwaway comment to me right it's
it's like this is where my relationships
with my family aren't a little more
important than the next most important
thing like this is it this is this is
miles above the next most important
thing and I think most people know that
but they get very busy and consumed with
other voices is telling them something
else and giving them you know immediate
feedback and positivity but those
relationships and at the end of my life
is completely obvious to me they're on
my deathbed I will not be saying well
how many people did how many how many
books a poke right right that isn't
gonna be it's just gonna be those people
around you the tape right like those
people in the room that small group
that's who it's gonna be about and so I
want to invest now with that clarity the
carat hour will have then that's a
beautiful story the premiere other
essentialist that i november Geron matte
phrases crossfit coach and yeah the very
very well-known and great podcaster who
I'll be presenting this episode to he
has a number of tools I think that you
suggest as ways that people can actually
instantiate the essentialist mentality
and one of the ones that he has is a
5:00 p.m. every day he's home I want to
say I want to say to 5:00 p.m. every day
that it might be 5:00 p.m. every day
that he shuts his laptop but apparently
there's like he's got a ton of really
hilarious stories of like they'll be in
the middle of this crazy important
business meeting and Ben will just start
packing his bag and it'll be with
someone who doesn't know that that Ben
leaves at 5:00 or whatever it might be
and boom battle start sort of packing
his bag you'll still be talking and
they'll still be talking and then he'll
be so I've walk-in yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's good gettin his phone getting his
water bar yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
really good walking away and then he's
like oh okay that's me I'm off bye bye
like it's 4:59 like and then he's in the
car and that's that's one of his very
very hard points of kind love that story
love that story and what I now at now I
now I want to meet him he's you will
adore him man he is him and part the
other the other you see that's that's
what it is and and and I I struggle with
that a little myself because I enjoy the
conversation of what I'm doing that's
the Suncoast bias all you want to be in
here instead of just you know that's
like permission a story like that helps
to give us permission all of us could do
that we think we can't but it's because
we haven't tried it who we don't know or
rather it might be that we can't do it
in the sense that there may be some
negative repercussions to suddenly
behaving that way but we don't know
because we never try we don't try it how
can we say it can't be done we don't we
didn't do it try it see what happens I
have a nephew where every every week we
I call my extended family they're all
nephew is in New Zealand and people all
over the world and they join in and he
he comes on and whenever he's done he's
just done he's very friendly but he's
just that oh yeah
he's out there's no like false
you know like false landings all the
time I'm like professional not Lander
yeah like conversations here and he just
I'm out that's it we could do that we we
do have a choice to operate that way but
sometimes we need to hear other people's
stories to really feel like it could be
possible for us I think that's the
importance of examples you know that's
that that's the the importance and we
were talking about this before because
your new podcast which will be linked in
the show notes below and you should
absolutely go and subscribe too because
I'm sure it'll be great and you've got
some fantastic guests
I'm incredibly jealous of on there and
we were talking about that talking about
just how important sort of fiction
stories and tales and stuff like that
are you know you can take from me
telling you about the fact that Ben
walks out of meetings of his CrossFit
gym yeah whatever whatever time and it's
kind of like semi awkward but semi funny
but wholly respectable like the fact
that you know that he like hang on a
[ __ ] second like if that is a habit
and there's two ways to look at it
actually I think a lot of people might
discount that so we get them that's
[ __ ] Ben Bergeron you know when Ben
can do what a man sees yeah yeah yeah
and you think right okay but maybe
you're putting the cart before the horse
there maybe you're saying member
Johnny's been bergeron therefore Ben
Bergeron can do Ben Bergeron stuff as
opposed to this is the strategy that is
implemented by him which has allowed him
to become the person that I think of as
being so impressive yeah well wish do we
really think it is but what really is
logical about that what we really think
that somebody became something
impressive and then became disciplined
rather than became discipline and then
became successful yeah but I tell you
that people say this sort of thing to me
all the time
all you essential isms all right to the
people that are like already at top
performers or even CEO already that this
or into that and I think yeah man you
this is this is you've got correlation
and causation backwards here this is the
course this is how people achieve what
they do in the moment they stop being
selectively thoughtful and disciplined
is the same point they plateau and can't
break through and continue to contribute
awesome so I want to finish off so that
the listeners have got some some tacit
takeaways about how we can how we can
execute and how we can make sure that
the vital few things are effortless and
the trivial many just you know they they
stay in the shed
oh you just want me to do that I would
love to find out I mean if you could do
it for me
that would be better but if you could
give us some some ways that we can
instantiate it that would be that'd be
wonderful here's one thing people can
start with it they can start with a
reverse pilot right now reverse pilot
like what is a pilot a pilot is trying
something out and seeing what happens a
reverse pilot is stopping doing
something and seeing what happens just
just stop choose one thing that you
normally have look on your calendar you
take one thing and you just cut it off
I'm not gonna do that
what like you can look okay I'll do it
right now I have a meeting Sunday
morning it's not a it's not like a
business meeting I'm not I'm not failing
this is like a like a actually it's a
church meeting that I do but that that's
out of date I shouldn't be still having
that at that time and it's gone now
maybe it won't be maybe it could be
checking your phone in the morning of
course it could be checking your phone
in the morning take take your phone out
of your bedroom you are among friends
here you are among very good friends
here there's actually there's you know
what we should send a link out with this
with a 21-day challenge that I put
together it's 21 little things that
people can do especially be trying to go
from memory right in a second but one of
them is that right you have a tech free
room certainly your phone shouldn't be
there I once worked with a lady who was
doing a Steve Harvey had a TV show and
he was it asked me to work with one of
his guests and I went to her home and
going around at home looking at where
she's at where she's too busy and
cluttered and and then I asked okay
where do you put your phone and well in
my bed in your bedding me by your bed oh
actually in my bed you under under my
you know under my pillow at night she
sleeps with it under a pillow and
there's two things I love about that but
one is like its course is horrendous
which you really wait two
middle of the night true if anyone texts
or email she wakes up response puts it
back so this is literally true that's
the first thing but the second thing
that I think is equally horrendous is it
is the rest of us our self-righteousness
about it feeling it burbling in me at
the moment and go
you're probably alright because I know
you don't do this but but there's so
many people I've shared that story with
who say ah raises shocking and I'll say
well where do you put your phone and
they say well you know my bedside table
self-righteousness is built upon twelve
inches and so what's the difference is
hardly a difference in that story I mean
take the phone out it doesn't know you
do know you know people people had alarm
clocks before they had phone so that's
no it's oh it wakes me up in the morning
yeah you can solve that problem in an
analog solution you have a little alarm
clock and the first thing you didn't
want don't have to be checking your
phone last thing at night first thing in
the morning
you know who's who's owning who are you
listening are you listening everybody
out there this is Greg McHugh and
telling you what I've told you for two
years and if you didn't listen to me
please for the love of all that is holy
listen to him you know another thing I
think is put put a little nap in your
day isn't as often as possible even if
it's an eight ten most 20 minute nap
every day every day why you because
because people are sleep-deprived and
when you're sleep-deprived do them to
make you tired when you're
sleep-deprived you're the executive
function of your brain goes down so you
can't discern properly between what's
important what's not important so the
business cycle continues so sleep is of
course it's restorative and all of these
things but high performers as a general
rule and also as the research supports
Erik Anderson's research about top
performers suggests that not only do
they spend more focus time working on
like one air
of expertise but he also found that the
number two in fact most correlated item
to distinguished the most the top
performance from the ambush performance
as they might asleep they got the top
performers sacked on average eight and a
half hours in every 24 hour period 8.4
if I remember right and they took more
naps as well because every moment they
were actually practicing or doing their
work they were really focused and that's
what asleep and the naps allowed them to
do is it's not just the number of hours
you're doing a thing it's the number of
focused hours you're doing that thing
and so yeah yeah take a nap for sure I
have I got more I've got I've got a
confession to make before you do that as
they saw what I was listening to you and
Tim Ferriss in the garden today having a
little sunbathe they just weren't just
slightly pink so I'm gonna get video guy
Dean to bring the saturation down on my
my side of the video and I felt I fell
asleep for a roundabout sort of it was
beautiful it was real engaging really
interesting notice it was just a 15 15
little 15-minute er and then I got one I
got woken up by the ice cream van yes so
it was perfect but at you know I just
felt I'll put it in there so yeah what
else we got that's the whole point is of
course you needed that little sleep of
course that was better
yes that's better use of your time of
your preparation was taking that nap
than spending those 20 minutes just
listening to more stuff you were more
alert more able to be here okay next
thing every day make your list of like
you know whatever six things main things
you're gonna do three things business
three things personal make that list
every day don't work from her to-do list
from yesterday that won't do there's so
much has already changed over the last
24 hours every day write it out put it
in priority order and then I only joke
half jokingly say this cross off the
bottom five right like that top thing is
if you've done it right is so important
you really need to spend the energy on
that until that's done and once you've
got that resolved and of course you can
move on to item number two
that's simplest prioritization process
it's not like that's so hard actually
it's pretty relatively easy but people
don't always do it and if you're not
doing it start doing it because the the
return on investment of getting the most
important thing done at every day over a
period of even three months or six
months over the course then of course 50
years is immensely different that says
what one more practical thing that
people can do
that's like a microcosm a to-do list
microcosm of the essentialist philosophy
I guess isn't it brought right down to
all that would be you'll be ten things
maybe ten things and cross off the
bottom nine
I guess 90% to ten yeah that's right
I like that okay I can say it ten things
we will do down to down to the one that
that's the idea and that that simple
that simple
step each day is like essentialism at
the cutting edge of execution who is
what you want to know each morning when
you've done through that process is
what's important now you know that's the
win what's important now and it's the
top item on that list and you work on it
and then once you've done it you have
permission to move on to the next item
every day every day every day you go
through this process you'd be amazed at
how much you can accomplish of the
things that matter if you aren't trying
to go from some very generalized list or
even just a mental list that you have
all this clutter that's in your mind
you're just actually working I mean I
literally have my I won't show it
because it's personal things but I
literally have it I'll show it very
briefly I do it on huge pieces of paper
actually always in sharpies that's my
method
I imagine do you hold the pen like this
as well too I love having it and I love
throwing it away at the end of the day
doing it in the next day so that you're
always actually focused on what's
important now not what was even
important yesterday or a week ago I
noticed you haven't used the word urgent
once there yeah yeah well I'm not I mean
I want to give agency to the things that
are important not let the urgent things
regardless of their importance
consume me so so yeah III that's true
maybe to a fault but I I definitely
distrust the urgent things in general if
other people are doing them if they're
urgent I just have a you know my spidey
senses like don't think so probably not
for me I want to take I want to take the
path less traveled I want to take the
path that only I can take right I want
my children but I want each my children
to take the path only they can take
their unique and essential mission in
life
and and I think that can be introduced
at any age so even though it's not that
tactical I think the questions I was
just talking to David Allen on my
podcast and this week and he said we
talked about all sorts of things he has
this thing he says there's six horizons
of input like you know six horizons of
of prioritization numbers like highest
level of a six is your life's goals and
then it goes down all the way down to
like zero is like what you do right now
so it's just a time horizons and then
we've got talking about this hey and I
started realizing there might be a
seventh horizon you know above life goal
and we got talking about that won't get
into all the the interesting
conversation behind it but in the end
his end point was he said he said yeah
he said the real questions we need to
ask aren't horizon six basically
agreeing that there is horizon seven
that he's never addressed in any of his
books or anything and he summarized
those two questions as Who am I and why
am I here and as I listened to those
questions I think yeah if you never
asked those questions the stuff on your
to-do list the stuff in your Mentalist
could be completely wrong directional so
essentialism isn't just about doing more
stuff efficiently it's about doing more
of the right things and so it
presupposes that first you are actually
asking those questions that you're not
doing it one sort of blue mood when you
you know you have some deep conversation
around a fireplace somewhere yeah three
hours and oh and then forget it
or not actually you're like leading with
that that's the work of life every day
you're going to do am i right we taught
that to our children so I children went
when I Elvis was she figure actually
want to be a director which is like ten
years old maybe she was 12 but she was
really got it right at that point and
she'd spent a couple of hours one night
answer me asking these questions well
Who am I and why am I here and what do I
want to do and what's my hundred year
vision literally because that's like
what we were talking about with her
that's really legit and and she she
wrote that she wrote this whole note and
put it under our bedroom door we got it
the next morning it's just all this she
knew she'd figured it out this is what I
want to do and she's been just able to
focus so much on that ever since I think
of how far she would accelerate if you
knew that from the time you were 10 11
12 years old she's done internships I
mean she's at university by the time
she's six 16 years old she's graduated
high school early she's a university 67
she's taking classes in she's think of
how focused that clarity is allowed her
to be and how much she's learning and
understanding internships for all sorts
of companies and stuff being on set
learning helping to see from shots and
angles anyway I just think that's like a
pretty it feels very high level but it's
a very practical thing to start asking
those questions now and tying it to your
to-do list each day and look what you
can become but that is how you spend
your life right the actions that you
take every single day will contribute to
the micro achievement will contribute to
the medium-sized achievement and that
over time compounded is how you are
spending your life and to loop it back
to one of the first things that we said
is you don't have the choice to not
spend your life but your life is going
to be spent for you whether you choose
to do it consciously or whether you
allow the societal norms and your
previous positions and your genetic
heritage and you're dealing with trauma
and all of those sort of the baggage and
the things that you brought with you to
determine that for you and the best that
you can hope for is to be the smartest
rat in the room if you don't work out
what's going on you can you can be a
rich successful or famous slave and that
is the best that you can hope for
smartest rat in the room it's brilliant
I think I think one of the highest
praises but also one of the things I
have found least so saddest too since
writing essentialism is how many people
will write to me or make a comment
online saying I wish I'd read
essentialism 20 years ago 30 years ago
as much as 50 years ago
something very you know sad about that
be quite an empathetic person am i yes I
certainly certainly feel for people I
certainly certainly care about people
and my wife is is an empath so she's
like very very strong in this regard and
so I've always got like a high standard
to sue people I'm comparing against but
but I certainly feel for those people
and and the sense of a sense of how
early could we get to the point where
we're asking these questions we're never
gonna regret that we may regret lots of
things but we're never gonna regret
having started as an essentialist right
now you know you're not gonna get to any
of our eyes off I just should have spent
more time on Facebook you know I just
should I should have worried about
everybody thought about me I should have
spent more time judging everybody else
to spend more time in email uh I want my
ear I want my tombstone to Rea read he
checked email yeah we're never all
ridiculous ugly but so I really want you
know on that day to have decided on this
one to live and lead more as an
essentialist
amazing phenomenal man thank you so much
this has been I mean I I am real excited
for your podcast to come out tell us
about that when when are you intending
on launching it and can you tell us who
the first episode is gonna be well the
first episode I can tell you the first
episode will be with my wife that's cool
yeah because she's the most important
person
that sounds very sounds very cliche now
or something saying that out loud that
I'm I've said that but but really it's
is the episode you know I want it to be
called the birth of essentialism because
there is no essentialism without Anna
there's a key story in the book but get
into it now but the key story in the
book as to what
to sensualism that relates to my wife
and and so it's just that and it's the
story behind all of that you know
essentialism simple we're trying to live
in our lives it's not something that we
just talked about elsewhere so I just
wanted the priority person to be the
first interview and actually like really
insisted on that with my production
company with the production company I'm
working with so that's the first person
I don't know who the second is yet
actually but you know could be could be
Tim Ferriss could be Ryan holiday could
be Arianna Huffington there's a whole
bunch already recorded done I'm not sure
the order that would come out and we
just I'm just really enjoying doing is
the first time I created a class at
Stanford called designing life
essentially and and it just for the
longest time I have not had a way of
sharing those practical things with
other people and just recently a finally
try it started to change that so there
is a skill share class I just launched
through Skillshare called a simple
productivity take some of those
practical things and just that I've
learned you know that makes that
available for anybody who wants to learn
about the how-to and this and the
podcast that's what it's about it's
about talking to people having
meaningful conversations and trying to
give them you know like you were saying
with Ben's stories and examples from
people's lives about how they are
wrestling with what really matters
amazing so what's the name of it going
to be people want to search the current
working title is essentialism with Greg
McEwan one of those words goes in I
should be alright yeah and you don't
come up there's something something's
gone wrong yet so that'll be linked in
the show notes below I will find the
skill share course as well and then is
the 21 day thing is that part of skill
shows that's somewhere else no it's not
in the skill shared thing if you reach
out to me will my office get that to you
so we can make that available to
phenomenal thank you so much I mean I
love these conversations I have to say
this is I could spend all day doing it
and I think increasingly over time as
I've done
or more of the podcasts this feels as I
sort of low-key keeps saying the closest
thing to a high is calling I've ever
found yes and yeah you're built to do
this Chris yeah I hope so I think so and
I think I think you know if if I keep on
doing if I keep on doing what I'm doing
I really think that me and the little
little tribe of people that we've got
coming along at the moment could could
go quite far and I appreciate you giving
me your time in there and being a big a
big part of it's phenomenal man thank
you so much bit of real pleasure thank
you
[Music]